the first and foremost question about
Paradise has to be about Blake things
seem to get really bad really fast for
Blake where do you think he went wrong
going to stagecoach apparently Blake's
just a young man who got his hand caught
in the cookie jar a few times
sleeping with Hanna City Bank right
there so how bad do things get for him
is there any redemption for Blake well I
mean things get about as bad as they can
I my thing about Blake is this
he made the initial mistake and it was
it's bad it's just there's nothing good
about it
the initial mistake being the stagecoach
the disaster that was stagecoach where
he was with Christina the next night was
with Caleb not a good look
not a great move not smart at all
thinking he was somehow going to get
away with that and just stroll into
paradise and he was gonna be just this
great time he would move on that is what
is beyond me
that's what I don't understand what was
he thinking was going to happen he seems
upset that it's on camera well I think
with with Kailyn apparently they had
some sort of understanding I think the
understanding was in his head that she
was just going to quietly go into the
night and hey I'm just gonna come in and
do my thing and still look like a great
guy surprisingly Kailyn didn't go along
with that and then I liked how he kind
of then put it on her so again there's a
lot of bad moves compounded by really
bad decisions compounded by stagecoach
Paradise has kind of become a place for
the term F boy to live and thrive is
Blake the worst offender in Paradise
history with the way he's treating some
of these women well I think you've seen
in the in the ads the Dean will be in
paradise when Dean looks at you and says
wow you really you've really gone a
little overboard in that department
that's saying a lot
because Dean is the gold standard right
but when
Dean and his mustache both judge you you
know you've done wrong
there's a lot of maintenance that goes
into keeping this thing as beautiful as
it is okay and Blake also seems to
really spiral real quickly I mean we see
him saying I gotta get out of here
what is that breakdown like and what
we're producers kind of saying to him to
keep him in check
probably the other biggest surprise for
me with Blake is that he didn't leave
and I mean I just would have jumped into
the ocean and swam I just would have
left I don't know why he didn't leave he
would have pulled a castaway 100% I like
me and Spaulding or Wilson was it Wilson
I I just laughs I mean I don't know what
kept him there and that is the amazing
thing about paradise and about the
bachelor/bachelorette it's like he still
thinks somehow he's gonna maneuver this
and you know what Hanna gee yeah I'm
gonna go make a run at that yeah and
then Hannah starts making out with Blake
and you know even Demi was like what are
you doing he's a loser what do you think
she was doing um I don't know but that I
guess is the beauty of the show is that
it's still like the fact that Blake
thought this has been the worst three
days of my life I have been outed in the
worst possible way I'm not gonna leave
I'm gonna triple down I'm going to after
making out what tisha want to go for
Hannah okay so do things end happily for
Blake I'll see how they could okay right
I mean is it possible maybe it's
paradise okay okay I don't see how they
could and no note to Blake no music
festivals this year but he does seem
sort of surprised that his exes keeps
showing up and this seems a moment of
dude you do know this TV show right
really that is the biggest question of
all what were you thinking yeah on so
many levels and and of all that to be so
it's almost only arrogance I guess to
think that you were gonna stroll into
paradise and that we wouldn't know as
producers that the girls weren't gonna
talk that everything would just
magically go away because you're some
great guy and again maybe he was
believing the hype drinking his own
kool-aid thinking that all the people
that tell him out and
like that he's the greatest guy ever
maybe he thought he was the greatest guy
ever and maybe this is exactly what he
needed was a swift kick in the ass okay
so what can he do from here
hopefully just grow and learn and you
know look we all let me just say this
about Blake he's not a bad guy you know
he he didn't rob a bank he's he's not a
terrible human being he didn't do
anything illegal yet he is single that
part he got right I am a single guy he
also needs to realize just because
you're a single guy doesn't mean you can
do what you did the promos for this
season look insane you have said best
season of Paradise ever is this season
the season with the most sex Paradise
has ever seen I didn't count my abacus
got lost I don't know if it's the most
sex
well here's the thing we've come off the
season with Hannah or she just said what
happened in the fantasy suites and it
was a powerful moment and it kind of
changed the game a little bit will there
be just more talk and more acknowledging
because even in the premiere we get
people talking about Blake and I hooked
up at stagecoach is there more
discussion well I it seems yeah maybe
you're right I think about I don't know
if that means there's more sex and
paradise I think there just maybe
there's more talk about past lives and
again this is the show evolving and this
is paradise evolving and the fact that
all of these people do go to stagecoach
go to all these festivals go to all
these events and and all these getaways
now where they're put up in Vegas or
whatever for a week and they all hook up
and they all commingle and they all talk
and they're all constantly maneuvering
and manipulating and that's what was
happening heading into paradise yeah
Blake was laying the groundwork heading
into paradise so all of them were we
know this we know exactly what they're
doing what they're up to the only big
mistake they make is thinking we don't
know and we can you say commingling yeah
commingling a nice word but yeah so yeah
we know and and the fact that they think
that they're just gonna stroll in and we
don't know this yeah but it usually
plans the best laid plans you having
been the constant in the show you are
seeing this evolution as a fan of how
much people talk about sex how do you
feel about seeing that discussion change
and evolve in every aspect of the
franchise bachelor/bachelorette paradise
I think it's you know the show has
always been a microcosm
happening in the real world and I think
there's more conversation about
sexuality sex race religion all this
stuff I just think a lot of a lot of our
taboo subjects are becoming more
commonplace and we're having a lot more
debate and talk about all of this stuff
in our households much less on the show
and so I think it's just bleeding over
and that's that's always been the case
for the show we evolved with what's
going on in the world and so I'm I think
it's better I think it's great I think
we're having some open honest
conversations I think you're watching
some conversations on the show thinking
yeah I mean my girls talk about that you
know my this that's what's really
happening on a date so you told me that
you'll probably wait until at least
towards the end of paradise to announce
bachelor yeah probably the end the end
yeah I don't know I don't know for sure
so don't hold me to this but it'll you
know just when the shows come up the
live shows it's towards the end so just
make sense that we wouldn't do it
randomly but you never know with us and
when I say you never know I don't know
who one pair could come out today after
this interview it could come out and I'd
be like yeah I know I knew about that
who is it
why don't know who on paradise my guess
is we're gonna announce towards the end
if not the end of paradise who on
paradise is a bachelor contender I don't
know yet Oh Mike I mean oh well yeah I
mean look there's some people on there
but I guess what I mean by not knowing
is I'm just gonna throw somebody out
there like Nick Viall like you know
Chris Bukowski or something I'm just
pulling a random one out there Chris is
not a candidate right now but I'm just
saying someone like that who all of a
sudden just pops and just goes nuts and
then everybody just gravitates towards
him and he has this amazing story and
you just you don't know and that's
that's why we wait now because in all
credit to paradise it's become a huge
franchise it's become so powerful that
it does move the needle and it didn't
used to do that so much that we had to
really pay attention to it now it's it's
a big deal and so someone could come off
this show and either be a complete
disaster and now they're out of the
discussion or now you're in the
discussion so it can be a game changer
well people have talked about Mike
Johnson yeah do paradise goings-on help
or hurt his chances to be bachelor you
footage I see I've seen the reality I
don't know the footage yet no I don't
know it's you know Mike's a good guy
I'll say this he's gonna come out being
the same good guy
he's a nice guy but so is clay so is
dare if we had it's it's a great cast
this year and what about Peters chances
for bachelor where do they stand these
days uh still flying high yeah up in the
air soaring up in the air safety first
no Peter obviously is a legit candidate
as well let's talk about Tyler yeah
Tyler you know a lot of fandom for his
bachelor then him and Hannah are getting
a drink then he's reportedly on a date
with supermodel Gigi Hadid what does a
gigi hadid moment do for Tyler's chances
for bachelor good on Tyler is that if
that is true I don't know it to be true
only Entertainment Tonight would have
such information if Tyler went on a date
with Gigi I also gotta ask what do you
think that says to Hanna because they
were definitely just together there are
confirmed photos of them having had that
drink right
well did Hanna say that they were just
gonna be friends or wanted to be friends
it could go either way
ya know yeah I've talked to Hannah and
Gigi gonna talk to an Tyler good on him
well but really they'll let me ask you I
mean you guys have to be looking at the
these months before these weeks before
bachelor gets announced Tyler's a
good-looking guy he's a model if he is
going out and dating supermodels and
other people how do you think that that
looks as well it definitely something
like that we're definitely way in the
conversation again why we're waiting
let's see how these guys react let's see
who really is sincere at the end of the
day because we do have a couple of
months before we have to start
production and really get into this and
so we have time and so yeah if Tyler is
bouncing around from girl to girl and
loving the life and enjoying the
limelight which by the way good on him
that's fine if that's what you want to
do right now I don't blame him he's
probably enjoying life really really
well but that's not someone we're gonna
want him have as our bachelor
bachelorette so it is if it's about
sincerity it's about where you are in
your life and if that's where he is in
his life then that's he's not the guy
for us
speaking of not the guy Jed Jed goes on
after the final rose with you
apologizes then he gets caught appearing
to like on Instagram comments of people
hating on Hanna yeah do you think Jed's
apology was sincere do you think he's
changed at all
to be honest I don't know him well
enough I haven't talked to him since
that day that we left the studio I've
heard the same thing that he wouldn't
like some stuff on social media I don't
know here's the thing about Jed I'm sure
he has regret I'm sure he was sorry I
really do think he was sorry he felt bad
because I talked to him off camera as
well that day and he was remorseful and
he hated how everything turned out and
how it came out because I do think at
the end of the day he actually did fall
in love with Hanna that part I believe
very much because this all happened
off-camera i sat with him and his
trailer before we went on camera and and
it was really weird how I think he just
kind of accidentally fell in love with
this girl and wasn't expecting it and it
kind of screwed everything up now go
back that he was trying to pull the wool
over everyone's eyes
I'll get we can go deep into that but at
the end of the day he fell in love with
Hanna and he didn't see that coming and
it kind of messed up everything
everything meaning his plans yeah his
plan his grand master plan for his
family the girlfriend back home all this
stuff it kind of blew everything up and
so I think it caught him off guard and
so I think he's remorseful and sorry for
a lot of the things that went down you
know I'm sure there's some things he
would like to say as well now that hand
has come out and been so vocal about a
lot of things that she did and and so
I'm sure he says his feelings hurt and
it's got a you know if he really did
love her which I do think he did the
admission of what she was doing with
Peter probably hurt his feelings the
admission of how much she really likes
Tyler and wants to go see him
immediately probably hurts his feelings
and hurts his pride in his ego so I get
it but do you think he was really sorry
for what he did to Hannah or was he just
sorry about how badly he'd screwed
everything well I think you can go back
to Blake are you sorry are you sorry you
got caught and there's there's a big
difference between that well it's
interesting cuz I actually was thinking
we're kind of watching Blake I mean
Blake's not Jed but we're watching Blake
through some
or lens of how we watched the JED thing
knowing what he'd done and now we're
gonna see everything play out are you
guys are kind of balancing that with the
show these last couple seasons like
things that have happened off-camera
your Sitz what we're actually getting to
now see is the behind the scenes of how
it all went down was that interesting to
you it is interesting how yeah I mean
there is a 24/7 cycle going on now with
the bachelor and bachelorette and so and
it does it bleeds into the show and it
used to be the show would create the
conversation that would there and create
the story that goes on and then those
stories would would live on after the
show now it's kind of the tail wagging
the dog and that their story coming into
the show that's creating conversation
and driving the story and you're having
to embrace that and Blake's a good
example and I think to our credit as
producers we jumped into the Blake story
night one you're gonna see that Monday
Tuesday night premiere night this story
is happening you know Kalin's in there
Christina Schulman is in there and even
there's a different story with with clay
that we haven't really talked about that
we'll get into about another story with
a girlfriend he was involved in and and
in other cast members and so that were
having to embrace for sure I'm so happy
that I found her and I can definitely
picture being with her for the rest of
my life talk about a story I'm excited
about which is Demi yeah what was that
like for you guys I mean the crew and
the production people you guys have
worked on this show for years and now to
watch the first queer relationship play
out was it emotional how did it feel for
you I'm really proud as a host a
producer and just as a man and a father
of two of how we handled it and at the
end of the day I always tell the
producers and most of them are younger
than I am all you can do is make the
best decision at the time and handle it
the best way you feel like you can and I
feel like we did it's sensitive subject
it shouldn't be and we're trying to kind
of rip that band-aid off but it is and
it's still it it's very you know it's
going to be taboo and I'm not so naive
as to think it's all going to be
positive the fact that we're doing this
and we're diving into this I'm
deme I'm proud of our producers I'm
proud of the way we handled it I think
it's great and it's time it's it's more
than time but I'm glad that we've done
it in the right way very organically
allowing it to happen naturally yeah
well I mean Demi had already said she's
gotten some hate already online for it
so do you imagine that's what you're
saying there will be more of that yeah
yeah I've talked to Demi you know I
talked to her after all this was over
and you know she was crying we were all
crying we're hugging and and we you know
we we were very careful of how we
handled this whole thing and I think we
did a great job but I told everybody
because ever we were we were in our
little cocoon and everybody was you know
I was very celebratory and very happy
and I said just know that there's going
to be negative that comes with this from
within that community and in from
without and that's that'll be the
interesting thing is within that
community we're gonna get backlash and
I'm prepared for that that's that's just
the world we live in with social media
everything else you didn't handle it
right you didn't do it the right way you
didn't do it their way everyone's gonna
have their spin on it their perspective
and how they want to see it this is how
we did it this how we portrayed it and I
will stand behind it
we love Demi she puts on a crown in that
in that intro she's the queen is she the
queen of paradise she's the queen of any
room she walks in I love Demi and I'm
you know again I think that you know you
don't get to handpick who you do
something like this with but I couldn't
have hand-picked somebody better because
I think she's up to the task but just
know that what you see what Demi is not
what you get she's not bulletproof you
know she's not a tank usually it's those
that speak the loudest and have the best
self-deprecating sense of humor are the
most sensitive and she is sensitive and
so I'm worried about her in that she
looks like she's strong and bring it on
and she she has that Queen mentality
but she's vulnerable and she has
feelings too and so it's I'm you know I
told her I was like I'm there for you
24/7 if you need anything because I
think it's gonna be hard for her be IP
has though been very successful in the
past I mean Jade and Tanner just had
their second baby on bachelor finale the
closets a closet Evan and Carli I mean
Ashley and Jared are getting there
how successful is this season what can
you tease Adam and Raven yes engaged
goose and crystal are getting married on
the show I actually marry them coming up
I think like maybe next week and so it's
it's been massively successful but again
you know people say why well the
percentages are greater there's 20
some-odd people running around on that
beach and so the chance of couples
coupling up is much higher this is gonna
be a successful season there will be
love found in Paradise rumors out that
another ABC show might be getting some
bachelor love Hannah may be going on
Dancing with the Stars Colton do you
know anything about this why is it Tyler
could we get Tyler Tyler dances yes he
had the whole Footloose thing yes that's
the biggie yeah so um I don't know I
really don't know who's on I really
don't don't look at me like that I don't
know but if ham is on she'd be great
Colton I don't think will be great
Colton's awesome here's goose what
Colton's gonna have to do just take his
shirt off from day one okay and use his
unbelievable charm charisma you mean
dancing won't be great yeah we saw him
in the bloopers for his season oh I love
cold yeah he's like my little brother
he's not a good dancer he could improve
no oh he has no rhythm okay at all that
doesn't come to you it could be great
television
it'll be great TV yeah and he'll go far
cuz here's the thing with Colton he is a
ridiculous athlete obviously he's a
world-class athlete and he grinds and he
will try so he will put in the effort so
I think you know but I'm talking he's at
a zero he might get to it too if he
crushes it whereas like a Hanna is a
performer I think she could dance you
know she'll be at a four can get up to
an eight okay so who do you think would
be more likely to win oh man
athletes have a great history on the
show but usually it's the athletes that
are good dancing good I don't know I'm
gonna say Hanna okay I'm gonna say Hanna
would have a better chance at winning
just because after a while we love
Colton people are gonna vote for Colton
because of that he'll be you know
shirtless with puppies and stuff somehow
doing the merengue but I don't think he
can go all the way I would love to see
just dancing with a puppy that's
probably what's gonna happen it was make
oh my god he's gonna win why haven't you
ever done it um why would I to brush up
on your rumba skills first of all you
know I could dance you know I have
skills you're right you don't need it I
don't feel like the world gets that for
me Wow
thank you for keeping it so personal
[Music]